[拍手]
うん
ウイスポーズ目社長だよ今日はこちらの
エーラーの多分ミント味だと思いますこれ
を
今日は貴様らの前で瞑想と思います
[音楽]
違うこれなんで書いてないかなあこれ多分
がちで買えてないですよ
選んでも書いてないでさぁ
赤いだったすっごい小さいんですよここに
ちょびっと書いてあるくらいなので
これはきっと僕みたいなコーナーか細い人
じゃないと見破れ
[音楽]
[拍手]
さっそく口の中に put in しよう
と思います
あー込みはちゃんとゴミ箱に捨てなきゃ
いけない実はゴミって英語で何て言うか
わかりますか
多分
がー丁稚って習ったと思うんですけど
我部ちっちゃねー
アメリカへグラス来て1死ではね語尾の
ことはねぇ
[拍手]
まさにさと嘘ですよ右してゴミのパットは
プラーズ違う
ラビッシュ我想う10社ラビッシュって
言って
ガーベッジがべっちって言ったらなんか
アメリカに帰るみたいなすっごく気になる
んで出来ればら wish を使い
ましょう
いろあさきと同じですね
問題はやっぱ人と同じで中身なんですよ
はい着色料たっぷりの色ですねいただき
ます
[音楽]
甘い断然ミント派ですねオレンジは
ちょっと何かあっ
美顔の川の味しかしなくて
もう結構僕のながらフラストレーションが
もうエクスプローションに使う
コンディションまで
きつ弾でエアロのピッチャーズ日本にある
かわかんないんですけどおすすめですと
いうわけで第二弾わー
エアロのマッツァずでした
[拍手]
ame
dea
[音楽]